hey who got [__] over worse Lance
Armstrong or Joe exotic that's a good
debate bro Rose oh we have it oh is that
is that what can you sing it it's a
debate club Oh Glenn it's Armstrong
first Joey my boy Michael Rapaport uh
Mike the rap the rapper Larry Bird's
evil twin this is Michael Rapaport aka
the pandemic Pied Piper aka the twinkle
man for the debate club the king and the
sting so did you guys think joe exotic
from the tiger King documentary series
on Netflix should be in prison what do
you guys think personally I think he's
the fall guy I don't think he should be
in prison
what do you guys think Oh everybody's
good hope everybody's safe and hopefully
I'll see everybody in person soon my
brother happy nice we did huh exotic
Jays brownies really yeah here's Anshu
with Jordan now oh my do you know about
them all the animals is there a real cat
on it that's yeah that's that right
there's that that's that cloud leopard
this is Panther that's a zebra that one
of them killed Dan you hear official
Tiger here oh and look at that lemur
backstraps up bro
that's it his beautiful dude dang your
Jordans I'm Williams or Joe exotic let's
go Joey oh dude this is those are
beautiful and this is a good question
man from Michael Rapaport happy 50th
Michael my favorite people on the planet
yeah Michael Rapaport he's definitely a
real loud mouth dude he is I'll say this
man he's definitely he's one of my
favorite sports people to listen to
because he's like he's like the white
Stephen a Smith really he should have
his own show
yeah yeah why doesn't he have that you
don't mean him we're gonna do our own
sports show on Fox really it's gonna be
me and him like shake
oh yeah and then he just gotta yell
he's a guy that yells at me about but uh
yeah the guy was like let's do this and
it was like everybody yeah some little
Muppets like yeah let's doing well yeah
put your mother in a body bag so I tell
you that tiger sanctuary yeah dude I'll
say this you know who's a real uh and
I'm not gonna say it out loud but POS
time had that tiger cut huh that tiger
cut [__]
oh no have you seen the doc yeah yeah
what's the whole thing dude I knew about
this years before man years ago yeah I
did it you did it
oh do doc I was watching my mouth was I
bro I've been following Joe exotic for a
while check out my Instagram like a year
and a half ago stood a picture I just
yeah he was your boy or what no but I
just know he's been out there I got a
buddy that even worked over at UM at GW
at that place for I guess maybe two
months just open the whole time ago yeah
have you ever been there huh
have you ever been ever been know him
but people were always like sending me
you know messages dude sending me
pictures thank you yeah you're not bad
you look you look like Joe exotic gayest
boyfriend you know his boyfriend's
aren't gay Brendan that dude comes there
just to play with the tiger some
good-looking normal dude six six
straight whoa hey they're driving he
goes how straight are easy pretty
straight bro he goes yeah when you watch
porn do you like to look at the big dick
so the small dicks he's like well the
big dicks
you ain't that straight and then it it
just time elapsed and they're married
yeah and they're in the dudes [__]
them now it's like ah you know if they
were having sex bro now they were
married he was in a relationship do you
see the picture where one dudes on the
ground like this is like the dude with
no teeth the meth heads on the ground
like this Jane oh no that's not James
and then they're both like and then the
six six dude in here we're just happiest
[__] yeah that little [__] dick
traps at the bottom one
[__] they had that boy little thirst
trap they set him down there dude dude
well there be imeem look man a lot of
beautiful men out there yeah what was
that
do you know when that was September 2018
this 2018 two years ago you were on this
Joey got it Yeah right there I'm
surprised you they didn't do a dot cup
with you on there dude I'm surprised in
an interview I'm not your queen up in
this video gesture or whatever uh maybe
though maybe they'd let me in there man
dude I'll say this though James
Garretson let's pull up a picture of
James Garretson dude is the real [__]
Fink who got uh he got caught on the hot
he got he got that hot lemur and you
dumb I'm on the dark web huh yeah no I
think he got it from Joe actually I see
the one with that he looks like the
owner of the Raiders is that [__]
yeah yeah well that little [__]
snitch yes yeah that little dumb yeah
right there dude that little [__]
cinnamon roll bro a little frickin knob
he looks like he sells Cinnabon on the
dark web
this [__] dude he looks like Young's
the Raiders he looks identical to the
owner of the Raiders right yeah if the
Raider guy just ate Cinnabon
bring him up make that [__] thirst
trap lemur this guy loves like Raiders
definitely been huffing york peppermint
patties on the side bright eyed dude
looks like a I don't trust that [__]
well yeah he had that dirty lemur and
that's he didn't want to go down so they
don't look identical bro mmm come on now
come on dude I need a better picture in
Jason you can't find it and it's James
he's an official employee of the US you
know I have some pictures of him on my
phone
really yeah I'll send you a couple you
know him huh huh no no no he's just been
texting you pixel oh he's trying to sell
you a lemur and [__] I snagged some off
the dock here we go you know what you
know what I got it why you gonna show
him on that jet ski with that dope rocky
music [__] they shown this dude
because they're trying to that was part
of the deal I bet hey man will like you
will make you look like a champ you know
we just need you to uh rat everybody out
here he is probably with a hot lobster
who knows where he
that bastard from dude he got a you know
some back-alley lobster right now buying
a lobster if I'm just gonna cook him and
eat him that's a thing man he had that
one shady lemur and he's running that
bootleg Dollar General over there you
saw that here by himself one of the
aisles have like tricycles on one of
them add beef jerky and that was all of
the aisles this is my store the worst
front ever dude there was definitely a
lot of drug-induced homosexuality and
that's one thing you see on this
documentary I don't talk about it though
can we talk about Joe exotic and his
meth habit the entire [__] time now
boy has some Slammers though his music
yeah say what you want about Joe exactly
but he creates some [__] I am her
hangers row a Slammers dude he
definitely he's that uh I'm out gay pogs
either now you know I'm saying he's kind
of like he reminds him like a um he
reminds me of somebody that works at a
carnival you know yeah the guy that runs
the thing that you hit yeah but he had
that pistol owna have you guys seen it
or not yeah yeah oh really what do you
guys think about it I was just I was
like okay where's the black people it's
Oklahoma bro he's in the middle of okay
people in Oklahoma not a title Griffin
in these only and then his brother to
who's a quarter yeah yeah brothers only
a quarter so there's literally it's he's
allowed but there's some question marks
as how ones I haven't one's a quarter to
but yeah same parents
I wonder mind one of the music videos
right now oh he got some real hits oh
man what was the one where they're
feeding up the meat to the tiger Oh
husband cuz that little [__] night
kitty kitty yeah hey kitty kitty
the girl who he got his archrival not
entrust Harold Raskin dude Harrell and
she killed her husband fed it to the
Tigers Carol Baskin yeah to say the full
name every girl basket and he's gonna go
down there here we go are you shared it
up
[Music]
[__] inside there good man I can't
believe
[Music]
and clouded leopards back
you notice I'm touching break slow and
mass boom oh yeah how did you do that to
me college I worked in the Dow War II
athletics ever
No
the situation
[__] dude it's not the kind of music you
want to listen to with your mouth open
though if you notice that hi I do feel
different if you're listening with your
mouth open it feels different
but Carol Baskin is a straight up
husband killer bro that h k bro you know
that [__] but what I want to know is
what do you guys think Colts corner
about the homosexuality that was in the
documentary cuz I enjoyed it I feel like
okay I thought it made a better story
I'm not a - bro what here just him and
his bro
oh dude that's I didn't find the man to
be gay that's all right that's all nice
and then the one dude who came was like
six six was like I guess I'm gay and
then again time lapse they don't tell us
anything he's married and then dude
spoiler Coosh in front of tigers killed
himself
yeah living a lie bro he was engage us
want to pet the Tigers yeah I mean no
they got him that's how they got him
they made him with a tiger and then hit
him with that meth cat and that did I
guess I want to touch this cloud leopard
that badass suck yeah Joe now I think
there might have been oral sex I don't
think that there was full-body sex
well that mouth head was down though do
you see the tattoo he got that said
property of joe joe said joe exotic
property only right above his dick piece
i didn't read it right above his
Tigertail right and then when he broke
up went back to the tattoo artist and
got a big old bull now here we have a
couple of the images right here so we
can see what you're actually talking
about give me the one where it's those
three of them and then the one thirst
trap on meth is taken to me like a
[__] high school football picture at
the top at the top it's the three of
them there you go on the right yeah
that's that's them tiger boys beautiful
man I talked about the Detroit Tigers
either now beautiful man yeah man I just
filled him right here a lot of frickin
captures and that boy in the bombs the
picture right now now I could see that
now I feel like that's what I felt like
there wasn't any full body sex going on
I felt like it was predominantly
probably oral sex oh you got anybody
else get that no not me you crazy you
know just wants all
you think Joe exotic doesn't put on the
jungle book and [__] these boys I got
your mommy you know sweaty them boys
getting the Oklahoma summers you kidding
me oh dear nope on meth it's hard to do
meth in the sunlight but I don't you
know anything about drugs
oh it's a winter drug yeah today's
warmest summer drug all right no I think
weed and stuff like that is more of a
summer drug so that's a nighttime drug
we those you need those uppers in the
winter when you get that seasonal
affective disorder
yeah just [__] feeding 300 it's hard
to do a lot of blow and be out in the
Sun you know you won't see somebody
doing blowing going you know laying out
by the beach oh I didn't know that you
know I don't know my drugs well it's
fine but here these men are right here
near a field or near a corn or something
beautiful to the one guy is pretty damn
beautiful I will say that I my boy on
the right yeah yeah all right marry [__]
kill with these three huh
wet better dead okay sorry all right wet
better dead with these three right here
man we´d better dare uh-uh joy exotic
I'm America's a boy he comes up with him
idea I can play with his Tigers all the
time I'm located Larkin for the market
marketing I'm gonna go ahead and kill
the boy taking an e on the Left I gotta
kill him dude get out of here I didn't
like his attitude and also when she got
tough he snitched on him bro he [__]
pro plan he's taking advantage of man
hey how about Joey exotics tight [__]
khakis and his [__] sticking out right
in that picture to get your dick out of
my boy's face and then I'm gonna go
ahead and hang out with the boy on the
right and probably just literally hang
out and play Madden or something yeah
he's not like duck hunt yeah what would
you guys chat am i off on this - what
about you I don't think you're off on
that at all Wow yeah whoo your choices
be cat let's get a female perspective
here since this thing seems
predominantly homosexual um who's the
best looking one cat eye
best-looking one is the guy on the right
young guy on the right I would bet him
because he's straight I would marry
straight except for jokes okay I don't
know
I think Joey's training it was a lot of
it just seemed like a lot everything
about him seemed like reaching for
something you know yeah almost like he
seemed like a fake gay to me now gun to
the head
how's he [__] with him Tigers probably
do know well yeah if it's gotta be so
hard to do though but is that gave us a
guy you're awesome it's pretty special
it's pretty special
it's way better than [__] just some
[__] that you met yeah you're right when
you're right you're right though but I
really the homosexuality that was going
on going on out there I feel like it'd
be so hard to be gay in that hot Sun
yeah okay look like a winter sport boys
agree my snuggle with a bear Harry dude
these guys in that Oklahoma God and the
Sooners are played got time to [__]
we got to watch the Sooners and feed
these Tigers yeah dude a lot of brave
gays out there Manning you don't know
that now we'll say this is definitely it
opens up a whole new breed of kind of
renegade homosexuality I feel like that
you're gonna start seeing really taking
over kind of the Midwest and the upper
Upper West it's gonna be you - if you
get that zoo in Mexico it could have
been 4,200 yeah no cases in Mexico
coronavirus no cases and we I'm sure you
get a [__] killer deal on Corona beer
right now we only said yeah beer in a
bat suit and bobcats and bat suit here
popped a bat suit that's triple B's just
feel I don't know man so many emotions
go through me when I was watching the
documentary because you feel for the the
the drug young fellas I got hooked on
the drug can we talk about his mentor
that had seven [__] seven wives Doc
anal dude [__] Devon bruh bog Devon he's
the real MVP he said it means Lord right
yeah yeah yeah what a curette like bog
Devon doc already has two titles and
then he tells you one of them means Lord
it's a bit much yeah that the whole
thing was strange that dude and then Joe
exotic the one thing
when I couldn't [__] with him is when he
was on trial and he threw his boy under
the bus his mentor yeah he's like he's
actually killing Tigers and he [__]
puts him in a gas chamber then he burns
ammo yeah that's your boy man yeah he
said he was like they were taking Tigers
and like waterboarding them and like
doing them on the right lights and stuff
like that and like I'm gonna sleep
yeah tickling him he said that they were
putting glitter on their tails and
tickling him the Tigers just giving up
all that [__] was not a lot of levels
man a lot of levels
hey what about when the girl's arm gets
a bit off not the best thing on TV is
that not the best of URC MTV and they
actually have the footage but my
favorite thing right arm off she's
laying there pretty calm she's badass
bro savvy yeah bad part my favorite part
is Joe exotic why he has a [__] huh
he is like a nurse's jacket on I have no
idea where he got it he goes his office
he goes hey y'all yeah I'll tell you
straight up right now I got to tell you
something man
I'm right here to hear about it on the
news all right somebody just get the
damn arm bit off over there by that
tiger all right so come back another day
or which is going give you money back
yeah yeah and they those Oklahomans
didn't give a [__] no one even budged no
look at this gangster Dale delaying man
[__] you there he is right there stay
with me stay with me he didn't really
snap in there look we really did why did
you have that jacket on though huh why
would you buy something like that he's
not a [__] pro you know you got to
grow up in a more rural area dude
everybody is a part-time EMT dude where
I'm from
dude look at that audience then when he
tells them yes once you just come back
no day all right young lady got her arm
bitten off yeah back up a little bit on
that Nicholas to get that little section
from them again so you got the gun on
Becky in the
says on this part Nikki back up a little
gun feedback in them goddamn Tigers back
up yeah lady and gentlemen fort here on
the news about an hour ago we had an
incident and one of the employees stuck
there on through the cage and a tiger
Toro Larry on the left one lady just has
a one jar a tiger but Tiger Balm she's
like I was gonna get my Jersey side
doesn't make sense I can give you your
money back I can give you a rain check
I brought my central field Jersey though
god dammit bro and if crazy party that's
the one day you want to be in the park
there that's finally gonna be there some
live action you'd only be at Six Flags
but nobody loses a [__] limb bruh yeah
I love that EMT jacket though where did
he get that we'll never recover from
this financially oh that's my favorite
any start to cry yeah well it's just God
there's my favorite part of the whole
documentary and part about being an
entrepreneur but then I have also being
like the the main dive the main guy
start you want to be the main event you
got to go back and forth between
business man and sensation and here's
the other thing though did nobody plan
for this did you not think out of all
the years somebody's get [__] their
arm ripped off by the tiger well yeah
but of course this happen hey how about
it what do you ran for president
oh yeah the balls on this man dude he's
under yeah that's the thing man I'll
tell you this I will say this one thing
I noticed about him I talked about the
documentary was that he's a hard worker
he's brave he was always involved like
anytime their load and stuff on trucks
or whatever he was never not involved
agree you know and I think I think he
[__] got the worst of everything and
everyone turned against him because they
knew he had talent and they [__] put
him in prison for 22 years true he does
have some Appeals coming up but I agree
it's looking like it's not gonna go well
but my favorite when he face times from
prison and his roots were growing out
and his hairs all [__] up
I thought it looked better with the
brown air now that blonde
oh dude that's local that's local
fairground blonde right there dude you
can only get that [__] color blonde
out outside of a roadie I bet you he's
thriving in prison though
oh yes booty galore that's another thing
bro but I don't know man
dude he's such a such an interesting guy
because it's almost like he would do
anything to find somebody that cared
about him or some were to find I don't
know I mean the level he went to to make
himself like things like yeah like just
I mean it just never ended it like you
know you're a documentary short like he
did a show every day for like six years
at 6 p.m. just talking [__] yeah
basically being on a podcast everything
live had 40 listeners still on that
[__] still on that [__] the work ethic
of joe exotic is insane and ahead of his
time he's doing that ten years ago it's
live streaming that's crazy
it's like Rogan he's the original Joe
Rogan yeah
Joe exotic really isn't crazy yeah I
wonder what they would talk about dude I
bet they never time to talk about I hope
he gets out man I think he's gonna you
know but here now here's the thing if he
got obsessed with wanna kill that lady I
don't know if he did cuz I did some
research on that lady okay she talked
about she's like I wish because they
wanted a Netflix want to follow up with
some of the people and like show what
they're doing now and she was like it's
weird because since I worked since I
worked for PETA I own a big cat
sanctuary she goes me and Joe really
like I didn't really deal with him that
much like he made it seem like there was
this whole thing against me she goes I
10 people that I was going after he's
just one of them Wow excite a bunch
going on it wasn't like I was focused
solely on him and he wasn't really
solely focused on me either she goes but
it's the documents you may seem that way
huh she was I got a bunch of [__] going
oh yeah definitely killed her husband
yeah but but do you believe her about
that stuff though cuz I like that lady
to me seemed like and that man that
husband met new husband man she had
something's wrong with that guy dude how
about when he was like Lonnie Baskin
ever leave you in spray
you can never leave anyway you're gonna
end up in a damn body bag Carl okay that
picture of him yeah just like a tiger
and she had him on like a leash on their
web I didn't see that on their wedding I
fell asleep during one of the episode
Carol Basque and wedding yeah Tiger the
[__] was always dressed up in some sort
of animal print - oh yeah I was the
print of her dead husband's finger
prints on her body
now I can get a libel print any at most
collab Nike dozen there's animal print I
pick them up I buy them but [__] dude
this [__] needs to relax look Joe
exactly I mean he peep oh [__] unreal
unreal
and that's your boy Lonnie Baskin right
there honey Baskin yeah [__] Barney
rubbles [__] yeah that's that but
this don't fit [__] Carney trouble
dude these guys are much too [__]
straight carnies out here right that's
what it seemed like it seemed like
somebody gave a couple carnies a tiger
and some money yeah and this is what
happens dude the shitty part is is
people like her or their do when she's
doing the same thing he would do the
exact same thing and cookie man down
yeah so you know he was making like 30
40 G's going to the malls showing kids
Tigers and [__] she's like nope not up
in here and shut that [__] down that's
why I hated her cuz he was like do I
need cover my nut by bringing these
Tigers to the mall no different than
what she does she said people go to her
sanctuary he bring him to the malls we
get paid for it so she stopped that
she's a [__] hater
she was a em she's the one that deserves
22 years and yeah dude and the thing is
also though they don't know you're not
gonna have these type of places anymore
that's one thing I don't like there's a
downside to all of that the documentary
and everything like oh yes we're gonna
shut this kind of [__] down now except
for her but I'll shut this the other
thing here's what the go on the other
thing is is uh I would never be that
comfortable to [__] hang out with
Tigers and [__] I've never been that
cool oh yeah never would you know the
[__] tiger really your kids named
Tiger you can't hang out with a live
tiger what do you think he's gonna do
dude we're not going there we're gonna
go on what are you gonna do as soon as
he can [__] be away from you although
he might go don't think I think about
the unexpected those places aren't
around
he'll exotic was a hustle I don't know
where you got all that millions of
dollars they opened that [__] up and
tigers we get a few up in this [__] the
only two grand dude we have three
walking around three thousand dollars a
year per tiger for to feed him Wow
not one not when they get older though
oh I don't know I I thought he was
cutting corners I thought he was like I
got it down to $3,000 I got a few pounds
well did you hear what he was doing was
he getting that Walmart me yeah and then
also roadkill yeah but it makes sense
yeah Tigers aren't like real you know
you don't see a tiger at the arm you
know at the zoo no you don't see one it
like a nice restaurant you know they
don't care what they eat
you know I catch a tiger at Sizzlers
yeah you might catch it
I mean Tiger would eat that [__]
Shoney's if it was open you know yeah
here's what though debates that would
they say
54% think he should be in prison 40% of
the six percent say no
that's a hung jury though isn't it is
that enough uh you need unanimous in a
jury so so one I just need one out of 12
yeah just one 12 Angry Men yep so you
have to have you need you so he would be
free then all right free hung jury yeah
yeah he'd be free the other thing is um
you know doctor breaks my heart man
me too cuz document but documentaries
all of them have they gotta paint a
picture right right so I feel bad for
him but then when you talk about you
know homeboy who came in was shooting
all his [__] and was in the Hat always
in the coffee shop I got see hate hate
yo exotic [__] hates on hue saying
he's the most evil person he's ever met
in his life but that guy also was kind
of a [__] nutcase did Rick Kirkham
yeah he was real tight I thought he was
the [__] Steven spielberger may
another selling this thing yeah and he
was really kind of right I mean that
thing I mean that show would have been
amazing he it was on today after this
let's say Joe exotic was out of prison
was doing the show now that [__] would
be poppin I mean watch it I bet Rick got
paid cuz he had all that footage he's
over the production no well he has
learned and some of that footage but
yeah
Joe exotic burned it all down I've only
seen the first three episodes that's the
thing about Joe you can't cross him bro
well here's any more necessary than down
and she was gangster man anyway he was
doing it for his brother his brother
commit suicide he was like this
dedication my brother and [__] built
this in
yeah but it also makes me it's like he
would just yell what he used everything
as a thing you know I mean I guess
that's life you know but it's some time
and a certain point it just started
nowhere and I don't trust I think
something's going I don't I don't like
anybody featured on the document I don't
like the drug-induced homosexuality
you know it's hardly enough if
somebody's on drugs and then you slip
I'm a dick you know behind behind the
pipe I'm not gonna lie that Joe exotic
talked a mean game I I don't want to go
down I'm scared about having myself that
Oklahoma boy drove down and play with
some Tigers listen you know he's married
what am I gonna do bro he did that every
toy you would want bro you want a gun
you want a tiger you want this why my
ATV yeah what do you wanna do let's
drive my wiener with your tongue I guess
so Joe can i play with the Tigers after
yeah dude you shoot enough bullets
Pettit Aki you don't even know if you
got a dick on you how do we know it's
right it's crazy
yeah they see you know that's straight
for you yeah it's crazy I mean you could
fall any throw a little bit of drugs in
there with guns and cats and big hands
you surround me with tigers I seen your
dick sound what do we do I'm at the
petting zoo man petting with my face bro
yes it could get real crispy out there
so how do you zoom here we got a
question right here from Paul Flores
Tigers real short this tiger heart is
spinning snake Oh God
back off bro sorry Tyrone I'll tell you
don't bring around exotic Joe bro you
gotta get out I do
I'm trying to get through this petting
zoo staff
[Music]
the King nothing